[Norvig] Here's one way to do it.
What I've done is I only changed this line, and instead of just returning r
for r, s in hand, I've taken r and used it as a lookup into this value.
So I'm saying when r is the letter 2, I look up into this string and say
what index is 2 in there and where is it?
You start counting at 0, so it's 0, 1, 2.
So the character 2 would map to the number 2,
the character T would map to the number 10, J to 11,
Q to 12, K to 13, and A to 14.
So that gives me a correct mapping from characters to index numbers,
and they'll all come out right. I could have done it other ways.
I could have had a dictionary lookup, I could have had a long set of if-then-else statements,
but this seemed the simplest way to do it.